we have something very dangerous going
on uh not only
do we have anti-vaccine conspiracies
spreading
at exactly a time when we most need to
be vaccinating people
so that we can be done with this
horrifying pandemic
we actually are seeing anti-vaccine
nonsense do
so well among the american right wing
that right-wing media is trying to
one-up each other
as to who can be the most anti-vaccine
and we covered fox news host tucker
carlson's anti-mass
comments last week we covered podcast
host joe rogan's anti-vaccine
comments as well i'm almost wondering
whether tucker carlson
was jealous about the attention that joe
rogan was getting last week
because last night joe uh not joe tucker
went even further off the deep end into
a completely unhinged
baseless and deceptive anti-vaccine rant
that unfortunately
is having an impact now for people
saying why are we talking about this we
are talking about this because we are
now at a point
where people just don't want to get the
vaccine and daily doses have been
declining for about 10 days now even
we're only at 44 of the country has had
one dose
32 percent of the country has had full
vaccination
vaccination should be increasing right
now but it's declining
because people uh are increasingly uh
not interested in getting the vaccine
from those that have not yet uh
received any of the doses so let's get
into the first
outrageous vaccine related clip from
last night that does not mean that they
are dangerous and we are not claiming
the chronos virus
vaccines are dangerous but we are
telling the truth
which is there are unresolved concerns
about their long-term effects on some
people including their effects on female
fertility
so first of all there's an image behind
tucker that says mandatory vaccinations
now there are no
mandatory vaccinations some schools have
said if you want to come to the school
you'll need to be vaccinated yes
and there there will be businesses that
may decide if you want to do business
with us you you will need a vaccine but
there are no mandatory vaccinations
from from government it's just not
happening nobody's forcing anyone to get
a vaccine
now the female fertility question is one
that has been raised but it is without
evidence
there is simply no evidence that the
vaccine impacts female fertility
now tucker says well we don't know it
hasn't been studied it would be like if
i
say we don't know the long-term effect
of the vaccine
uh on curling skill you know the olympic
sport curling
i mean yeah it's true it's not been
studied
but we have no reason to think that the
vaccine
impacts how good you are going to be at
olympic curling
and then he gets into some more specific
claims that are also deceptive take a
look
that is not a conspiracy theory that is
true
it's an honest question what's the
long-term effect that no one so far has
been able to answer
and it's not simply being asked by
partisans it's being asked by practicing
physicians
catherine lee for example is a research
fellow in division of public health
sciences
at washington university in st louis lee
doesn't seem like a partisan republican
or a q a on adherent or a crank she
gladly took the chronovirus vaccine she
seems to support the chronovirus vaccine
strongly
but then in herself she noticed
unexpected effects on her menstrual
cycle
quote it wasn't a symptom that was on
the list lee said
i expected that my arm would be sore or
that i might have a fever or headache
but this just wasn't on the list kate
clancy another scientist who studies
female fertility at the university of
illinois
reported that she had the same symptoms
after she got the vaccine and she wrote
about it in some detail on twitter you
could look it up
after she did write about it dozens of
other women wrote in about similar
experiences
they had had after getting the vaccine
none of these symptoms had been
described in the medical literature
the reason the clinical trials for the
vaccines never tested for the effects on
the female menstrual cycle or for
fertility or on pregnant women
so maybe the symptoms amount to nothing
that's often the case
maybe they mount to something we don't
know
the fact is we can't say what the
long-term effects of this vaccine will
be
on women including pregnant women now
you really have to pick
each thing apart there the statements
by katherine lee and kate clancy
about the heavy periods after the
vaccine
those are true statements tucker is
accurately quoting them
but it's not complete we know
first of all that menstrual cycles are
heavily affected by stress of all kinds
vaccines work directly on the immune
system the menstrual cycle is very
sensitive to anything that affects the
immune system
i know women who have mentioned
experiencing this then they went back to
normal after one cycle after being
vaccinated
what tucker is not telling you is that
the very same dr catherine lee that he
quotes
also said this would have no effect on
fertility
tucker tells you look dr catherine lee
said whoa heavy period
but katherine lee also said this will
have no effect on fertility
and tucker doesn't tell you that he's
only giving you a partial quote
and then tucker shifts into saying no
one is allowed to ask
questions honest people admit this
every scientist knows it according to a
recent study published in the new
england journal of medicine quote
more longitudinal follow-up including
follow-up of large numbers of women
vaccinated earlier in
pregnancy is necessary to inform
maternal
pregnancy and infant outcomes
in other words at this point and there's
no changing this because it's true
we just don't know again that does not
mean the coronavirus
vaccine is dangerous there is no proof
that it's dangerous
but there doesn't need to be now i have
to tell you
this is pretty sophisticated propaganda
in total
we can see through it but it but it's
actually quite sophisticated tucker
opens by saying
i'm not anti-vaccine he ends by saying
it's these vaccines may well be safe but
in between
he puts out carefully truncated partial
statements from doctors about vaccine
side effects
with pictures above his shoulders that
say mandatory vaccinations which don't
exist
no questions allowed as if someone is
silencing him
even though he's been doing this now for
weeks it's really pretty sophisticated
propaganda
let's look at one more clip nbc news is
now running and you may have seen these
psas public service announcements with
its on-air talent
demanding that everyone in the country
get the shot
barack obama just released this creepy
little video telling small children to
get the shot
hi everybody it's barack now that every
american over the age of 16 is eligible
to get the vaccine
i want to talk about you getting yours
the vaccine is safe
it's effective it's free i got one
michelle got one people you know got one
and now you can get one too
it's the only way we're gonna get back
to all the things we love
from safely spending time with
grandparents to going to concerts and
watching live sports
so get the vaccine as soon as you can
some creepy old guy telling your
children your little kids to take
medicine whose effects
we do not fully understand it's totally
normal yeah that that happens every day
don't ask questions just do it as cnn
explained recently
we're not getting our freedom back until
you do
the funny thing is trump said the same
thing as obama
just not at all eloquently it's not
about we can't ask questions
it's the questions have been asked and
they've been answered
trump said during that weird interview
in march i think with sean hannity i got
the vaccine people should get it
i don't know why people don't want to
get it it's essentially what barack
obama said no one's being forced obama's
just more eloquent in saying it and that
seems to really anger tucker carlson
but tucker only talks about barack obama
saying go and get vaccinated
when donald trump also said go and get
vaccinated on the hannity program
in a much less articulate and less
eloquent way sure
so this is really dangerous stuff
because tucker's audience
is made up disproportionately of people
who are vaccine skeptical
republicans at this point the most
coveted vaccine skeptical group out
there
and this is going to make it even worse
at a time when we just
we have the ability look at the israeli
numbers
they had i think 13 cases or something
like that
same size and population as new jersey
we can do it but people like tucker
carlson are making it more difficult
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious fruit drink powder that you
mix
into water for rehydration and they're
giving
you 25 off your first order
it's made with four key electrolytes
that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video